this is Godot one of the poorest and
most dangerous states in Mexico and
we're visiting a rural Teachers College
here called IOT NACA in 2014
43 IOT novice students disappeared in
the town of Iguala at the hands of state
security forces despite their absence
IOT Nava is welcoming a new class of
students
is their first years
ayotzinapa teachers college is what's
called a normal school colleges created
after the Mexican Revolution to support
rural education most students come from
families of farmworkers with little
access to university lo que podamos a
solution Appa whose Kizuna speranza
Santiago is a new student who's worked a
lot of jobs before coming here he's been
a Salesman a waiter a car washer samosa
Cho muchas cosas para para sobre beer
please
siempre de trabajo are represented Oh
Esperanza desde Chico el car gar no se
une époque al a socket a represent Abba
Westen a algún la bocca Akina yo tina
parven milpa LP de los animales le BR la
escuela significa Westerner formation
academic but here school isn't just
about hitting the books every day
students have an array of chores they
have to get done que estamos Armando yes
sir but I guess una Buena regular
requisition users if they Santos amigos
yeah
no I'm gonna scale what did I know
murals cover every inch of the school
depicting heroes and a history of
political activism this one I like it
says it's a protest is a right and to
repress is a crime in Mexico a person
has disappeared every two hours
this is escuela de lucha cierto here's a
lucha yellow so gentle nervous que
tenemos de historia
Accio de lucha pero también formal
orally disentis Ernesto is a second year
student and survivor of the attacks in
Iguala now he says his energies are
divided between seeking justice and
doing what he came to do at a yachty
Napa miss Perrone says primera mental
miss quality to the company knows
there's opium in the terminal los
estudios como
Santiago who found out about the school
after the attacks of 2014 says he isn't
afraid of being a student here is the
sufferer - no I meant a CIA vias goes
and total Mexico areas was there was a
logic I don't know estimate ando
maestro's for the stand defend oled
ocasion there was a Nortel Pais locus
Alvarez and Keating and lost campus in
the loss sustained encarcelado por estar
pasando por pow wows Cousteau's de sus
corner Lorelai's y en Guerrero a los
estudiantes versus tan voice
desaparición de por venir por una mejora
tu casa y por defender una normal que ya
become pure no ventanas de vida es creo
que onda Kyra estamos and open in seguro
como Mexico heylia's goes defending
their school is an essential part of
what being a normal ISA is many normal
schools have closed due to a lack of
funding and those that remain regularly
bargain with the government to keep
running no screen reduce la matricula no
square n Keitel Jodl in Karnad okay Todd
Elko
Anoka me no simple pero Claro ESO SI una
cosa say Ciaran are normal pública pero
si our in dos o tres previous the
disappearance of their 43 classmates
looms large as does the possibility of
the school closing then there's
graduating it's a lot to carry
and yet students like Santiago remain
determined mientras la escuela existe
aqui Savannah seguir construyendo
hombres consciente x' hombres con una
visión
de transform our la sociedad hombres con
una visión de Duke our y mientras Agha
profesores que salga de los lincolnís
mas por s del país see para ver speranza
a year ago on the night of September
26th a hundred students from the IOT not
the rural school came here to the town
of Iguala